colonna est un symbole mais c'est un
symbole en grande partie fallacieux il
faut quand même le dire c'est à dire que
les nationalistes ont quand même une
responsabilité dans l'hérault isation de
colonna moi je corps préfectoral
français même pas la corse en veut à la
corde sessad que de cet assassinat
terrible il faut pas trop essentialiser
les corses on est pas on n'est pas une
humanité particulière tous les hommes
cherche la reconnaissance tous les
petits peuples cherchent la
reconnaissance cette reconnaissance ils
l'ont trouvée à travers la france
lorsque la france était puissante et à
travers un pays auquel s'identifier
parce que c'était la grande nation
coloniale et ils ont été à l'avant-garde
de cette aventure coloniale quand la
france a perdu son empire est devenue un
pays moyen une nation moyenne ils ont
beaucoup moins chercher la
reconnaissance à travers la france il a
cherche maintenant à travers la corse
les corses font partie moi je trouve de
s'est assignée à résidence parce que
qu'on n'est de toute façon dans les
fêtes complètement dépendant de l'état
on est dépendant de l'état le premier
employeur dans les premiers rangs
[Musique]
surprise personne en soi n'est contre
l'idée d'autonomie si vous voulez
l'autonomie c'est une notion qui est
relativement consensuelle parce qu'elle
est en elle même on ne sait pas trop à
quoi on s'engage quand on parle
d'autonomie en soi autonomie est un mot
qui peut être tout à fait inoffensif
tout dépend ce qu'on met dans le panier
tout dépend de l'état d'esprit dans
lequel on construit cette idée
d'autonomie moi quand on a prononcé le
mot autonomie je rajoute autre chose je
me suis dit si l'autonomie c'est plus
d'isolement de la corse par rapport à la
république c'est dramatique pour tout le
monde le qu'est ce qu'on cherche moi moi
je parlais pas l'autonomie je parle
dialogue et confiance sur les grands
dossiers de la corse on les connaît ses
dossiers là il faut y travailler et je
crois que si mais on était prêts étaient
prêts à mettre beaucoup d'eau dans son
vin et d'ailleurs on le lui a reproché
bon maintenant je pense qu'il ya eu une
forte évolution dans les esprits
en corse dans l'esprit des autonomistes
modérés bon moi je dis toujours je ne
suis pas de l'hommiste mais j'ai voté
siméon donc qu'est-ce qui se passe il se
trouve il se trouve qu'il ya une idée de
dégager ce qu'on a voulu un homme ne
pouvoir que ce qui a précédé simeoni
n'est pas très brillant sur le plan de
la de la gestion politique corse non
plus bon et je pense que les choses
avaient beaucoup évolué et qu'on a fait
on a laissé remonter au fond cette base
idéologique dont vous parliez on l'a
laissé remonter très fort très vite et
qu'on l'a de nouveau sur le dos c'est ça
voilà on a de nouveau sur le dos et ce
qui m'inquiète beaucoup c'est qu'elle
risque de persister c'est que maintenant
la pression de l'idéologie
indépendantiste ps alors même que je
signale ce sondage de l'ifop il ya
quelques jours
soixante pour cent des français sont
contre l'indépendance de la corse mais
70% des corses ou contre l'indépendance
de la corse le paradoxe c'est ça et
d'ailleurs c'est pour des raisons
différentes je pense que ceux des
continentaux qui sont pour
l'indépendance de la corse et pour s'en
débarrasser et les 70% de corse qui sont
contre l'indépendance de la corse c'est
parce que ce sont des gens réalistes et
parce qu'ils savent parfaitement que
nous avons une gouvernance est un état
de droit en corse qui ne permettent en
aucune manière une perspective
indépendant je suis économique etc mais
que vous avez une série de sujets qu'il
faut traiter en même temps qu'ils
nécessitent un régalien très fort et un
vrai dialogue sur le reste voilà si on
peut arriver à ça on y arrivera la
question c'est est ce que l'agression de
colonna précédé par ces tensions entre
l'état et la collectivité nous met dans
une situation où on a fait vingt ans en
arrière est-ce qu'on as conseil repris
20 ans dans la vue ou pas il faut bien
comprendre que le symbolique la
dimension symbolique ça une énorme
importance encore cette question du
rapprochement des prisonniers
alors on va nous expliquer que c'était
très compliqué que l'école et prison
corps sont inadaptées à ce type bon très
bien
je veux bien entendre tous ses arguments
y n'empêche que pour des raisons
humanitaires il n'y avait aucune raison
de continuer à considérer que ces trois
prisonniers étaient des dangers publics
et que donc sur un plan sur le plan de
la sensibilité sur le plan affectif
c'est évident que cette revendication du
rapprochement des prisonniers en corse
en soit elle n'était pas idéologique
elle était elle pouvait se comprendre
sur le plan du sens commun tout
simplement on a eu l'impression qu'il ya
eu un raidissement absurde sur une
question qui est quand même très
subsidiaire bon vous avez des tas de
dossiers sur lesquels il ya eu des
tensions le ce type et yahia il ya une
raison à ça c'est d'une part pour des
raisons qu'on comprendrait bien expliqué
le corps préfectoral français même pas
la corse en veut à la corse c'est de cet
assassinat terrible et deuxièmement il
ya un fait le même mac revient plus
générale c'est que dans une région
normalement constitué vous avez un
préfet mais vous avez des grands élus
qui font partie de votre majorité à
marseille vous avez gaudin donc après à
marseille du temps de sarkozy vous aviez
le préfet qui venait dire un truc
bizarre gaudin qui disait mon cher
nicolas faudrait voir les choses de
manière un peu différente en corse il
n'y a pas de relais de confiance yahia
orsucci quéméré il n'ya pas de député et
donc ça certainement vexé macron de
n'avoir aucun député en corse et il n'y
a que le préfet et est donc le la
capacité de médiation politique
vis-à-vis du terrain est extrêmement
difficile à construire et je pense que
ça a beaucoup coûté à maquereau ça aussi
c'est à nous et à nous les corses
accessoirement bon
colonna est un symbole mais c'est un
symbole en grande partie fallacieux il
faut quand même le dire c'est à dire que
les nationalistes ont quand même une
responsabilité dans l'hérault isation de
colonna moi je vis en corse je vois
régulièrement des slogans des tags
gloria athée colonna il faut quand même
rétablir un certain nombre de normes je
dirais de normes intellectuelle et
morale colonna n'est pas un héros il a
fait partie d'un commando même si c'est
très anciens même s'il a changé même
s'il est devenu un quelqu'un de
parait-il exemplaire dans son
comportement
il a quand même fait partie d'une
opération criminelle qui a abouti à
l'assassinât d'un homme qui était dans
son qui faisait son devoir de préfet qui
était en plus relativement populaire en
corse qui avait réussi à créer des liens
et il a été abattu excusez moi comme un
chien après il faut entendre les avocats
gamberini quand ils disent que colonna
est un c'est un gentil garçon on peut
être un criminel à 25 ans et se révéler
plus tard être un gentil garçon parce
que l'idéologie vous fait faire des
choses qui sont invraisemblables
voilà donc colonna pour moi c'est il a
fait partie d'un commando criminelle et
en même temps il est la victime d'une
idéologie qui est absurde et qui a fait
de la france et de l'état français un
ennemi la jeunesse que j'ai vu moi à
corte que j'ai vue à bastia elle est
extrêmement violente il ya une violence
pulsionnel là bas qui s'est exprimé et
qui est extrêmement préoccupante il ya
quand même un policier qui a été tabassé
d'une manière incroyable et j'ai vu sur
les murs de bastia
des tags qui que je n'avais jamais vu ça
fait des années que je vois il francese
forme et j'ai vu gaulois sale race
français sous race donc c'est quand même
j'ai discuté je me suis disputé avec un
député nationaliste ces gens disent
c'est pas nous on n'y peut rien il ya
toujours des imbéciles dans un moule
d'accord mais on est un peu responsable
de l'imbécillité de ses propres franche
et moi qui suis corse profondément qui
me sens corse j'ai été blessé par cette
cette irruption de violence dans
laquelle je ne me reconnais pas et je
pense que les nationalistes simeoni qui
est quelqu'un je pense d'intègrer de
respectables aurait dû condamner ces
violences
il ya d'abord une période génoise
pourront à la période génoise de quatre
siècles et une période extrêmement
difficile de désordre public pourquoi
parce que les génois ils sont intéressés
à la corse au titre de sa position sur
les routes du commerce option
stratégique
ils sont intéressés à ce qu'on appelle
lé président c'est à dire les ports il
faut contrôler les ports et ils ont
tendance n'est pas des cycles 1 et ils
ont tendance à considérer que
l'intérieur de la corse doit rester une
sorte de de jachère
qui vit dans le désordre il n'y a pas
vraiment d'ordre public en corse c'est
l'instinct de survie l'autodéfense qui
quand même 2000 donc
ils se construisent une là dedans une
relative culture de violence 1 la corse
est acheté en 1769 la monarchie
considère que c'est une colonne et enfin
que c'était une possession 20 novembre
et les corses ne sont pas considérés
comme des sujets bon
et donc et à rim la révolution et
ensuite vous avez progressivement une
installation des corses dans le projet
national les paoli avait son projet
national pour la corse même napoléon
quand il était jeune avait son projet
national pour la corse et tout d'un coup
il sondé les corses nous on s'est dit au
lieu de fabriquer une petite nation
qu'on n'arrive pas à fabriquer
installons notre projet dans la grande
et et y avait un il ya eu un grand
projet national son projet républicain
ce projet colonial qui a fonctionné
jusqu'à la deuxième guerre mondiale
après la deuxième guerre mondiale la
décolonisation qui pose des tas de
problèmes aux corses puissent qu'ils
étaient allés beaucoup là bas vous avez
ensuite la fin des trente glorieuses moi
mon père était un parlement 14 je voyais
des corses arrivés dans les années 60 il
sonnait à la porte ils devraient
je voudrais si c'est possible un emploi
et un logement s'était fait le vendent
mal il y avait 6 % de croissance par an
c'est moins le nombre de gens qui sont
venus me voir quand j'étais plus jeune à
huy vers truc donc il y avait une espèce
d'organisation corse qui délaissait la
corse en tant que territoire qui
économiquement ne n'étais pas du tout
traités et mai qui donnait un
épanouissement encore de la république
et ce modèle en quelque sorte s'est
cassé dans les années 60-70 on l'a mal
vu venir et à partir de ce moment là il
ya eu une amertume corse quoique ça ne
fait aucun doute il y avait des
composantes indépendantiste
irrédentistes qui avait un peu de temps
titi qui était latente qui sont revenus
il y avait une culture de violence qui
était né du de d'un passé plus lointain
et qui avait subsisté bien entendu qui a
remonté et ça à fabriquer ses 50 ans le
ruban et il fit n'ai je pense que en
2014 les indépendantistes et les arêtes
la violence la croix son score ces
dernières années a été grosso modo un
point de plus par an que la croissance
française en général et et ça faisait
partie le monde de mon optimisme en
disant je pense qu'il ya un
développement économique corses qui est
pas forcément toujours équilibré mais
parce qu'il ya des problèmes fonciers il
ya ségolène mais mais qui fonctionne et
comme moi je suis dans le cap corse
comme vous le cap corse et étape est un
petit peuple heureux c'est ça se passe
bien on va demander l'autonomie oui oui
le cap pourrait demander ça sous-entend
qu'on l'accord sera indépendante on
demandera l'autonomie du 14 et donc et
pour revenir sur ce que vous disiez moi
dans ma famille on met toujours non la
corse ne va pas fait ça pas faire ta
carrière encore que ta carrière sur le
contenant ensuite à ta maison encore
survient pour ta retraite des terrains
est d'ailleurs l'enfant que j'étais sur
la place du village le vch covan dans
les années 60 voyez une richesse
intellectuelle
formidable faite d'expériences partout
des gars qui était commissaire de police
en afrique noire les gars qui étaient
dans l'eau l'homme qui était
intervenu d'indochine etc on jouer au
bridge d'y jouer au bridge comme des
rois elle allait l'aider les cafés de
vescovato les meilleurs joueurs de
bridge à mon avis de l'ensemble national
c'était exceptionnel et c'est ça qui
sait ça s'est arrêté c'est pour ça que
moi je suis frustré de ce que de ce
quinquennat perdu parce que je pense que
ça aurait pu se passer autrement et on
est revenus à nos vieux démons du fait
même du déroulement du dernier
quinquennat l'isl aventures des corses
par rapport à la france les corses y ont
gagné la corse n'y a pas gagné c'est à
dire que pendant que les corses y ont
gagné parce qu'ils sont ils ont cherché
et trouvé une certaine forme de
reconnaissance à travers l' aventure
française et notamment à travers la
peinture impériale ils se sont expatriés
ils sont devenus fonctionnaires soldats
militaires journalistes avocats tout ce
que vous savez administrateurs mais la
corse elle elle a stagné et quand la
france a perdu son empire colonial
les corses se rendus compte mec que là
ce qu'il leur reste et c'est à dire la
corse était un pays relativement sous
développés et la s'est développée
l'amertume parce qu'autrefois les corses
partait il partait dans l' empire
aujourd'hui les petits jeunes ils le
disent nous on veut rester en corse ils
ont localisé ils se sont recentrés sur
le local et date et on le voit même dans
le milieu criminel c'est connu quand on
étudie l'évolution de la mafia du milieu
criminel le milieu criminel qu'est ce
que c'était milieu criminel corse eh ben
ils s'exporter à paris à marseille ils
étaient tout puissants depuis quelques
années ils sont revenus en corse et
c'est d'ailleurs un des problèmes
dramatiques de la corse et ce pour quoi
il faut un état régalien fort en corse
et là aussi on touche la contradiction
des nationalistes j'ai eu un débat avec
colombani le député nationaliste on
s'est un petit peu engueulé mais j'ai vu
son discours l'assemblée nationale le 2
novembre face à un mètre du conte le
riti il se plaignait que l'état
n'investissez pas assez de de moyens
régalien pour combattre la mafia et ce
sont les mêmes ensuite qu'ils vont
expliquer qu'ils vont diaboliser l'état
français donc on est en face d'une
incohérence et d'une quasi schizophrénie
langage et je voudrais faire juste un
petit ajout il faut pas trop
essentialiser les corses on est pas on
n'est pas une humanité particulière tous
les hommes cherche la reconnaissance
tous les petits peuples cherchent la
reconnaissance cette reconnaissance ils
l'ont trouvée à travers la france
lorsque la france était puissante et à
travers un pays auquel s'identifier
parce que c'était la grande nation
coloniale et ils ont été à l'avant-garde
de cette aventure coloniale quand la
france a perdu son empire est devenue un
pays moyen 1900 moyenne ils ont beaucoup
moins chercher la reconnaissance à
travers la france il la cherche
maintenant à travers la corse
il ne venait il ne m'est jamais venu à
l'esprit
de me poser cette question d'accord bon
moi je dis d'ailleurs pour moi lille et
du peuple corse jeumont parlons je vais
te dire ça m'est complètement d'un
différend je me moi je me dis les choses
de manière différente la république
n'est plus unique la république et plus
assez forte pour être unique quand
darmanin dit dans corse matin il ne peut
pas y avoir deux types de français moi
je réponds non mais c'est pas le sujet
des français y en a 25 type il y en a
250 types le problème c'est de les faire
vivre ensemble dans une seule république
voilà voilà donc si on me dit le peuple
corse est partie intégrante du peuple
français qu'il faut relire mona ozouf il
faut venir composition française or la
république c'est la mise ensemble d'un
certain nombre de peuples qui étaient
dispersés à l'intérieur d'un projet
commun qui effectivement nous à nous à
intégrer dans une culture qui a un peu
effacé la nôtre la république a changé
il faut accepter un certain nombre
d'amodiation à l'intérieur d'une
république unies sur les bases un peu
différente voilà ce que je pense je suis
content je suis content que vous
repreniez une
une formulation que j'ai et que je
développe je pense que cette question du
peuple corse est une fausse question
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
qu'il ya une personnalité corse le
peuple corse est quoi ça existait sous
pascal paoli c'est d'un peuple c'est
qu'une collectivité en devenir c'est une
population qui donne un sens à don à son
destin c'est ça un peuple c'est une
population qui donne un sens à son
destin sous pascal paoli avait un peuple
corse qui est allé vers une sorte
d'indépendance ensuite ce peuple corse
est mêlé au peuple français les
fréquences et les français notamment par
les mariages mixtes vous avez encore des
nationalistes qui sont mariés avec des
pin's hood avec des femmes du continent
vous en avez plein qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire à ces gens le jour où on leur dira
vous allez devoir choisir entre la
citoyenneté corse et la citoyenneté
française on sera dans une situation
aberrante dans un arbre au lieu donc le
peuple corse il a existé en tant
qu'entité il s'est mêlé il a mêlé son
histoire et ses gènes avec le peuple
français est aujourd'hui c'est
indissociable
encore vous avez le tas de gens qui sont
pin's août qu'ils sont français qui se
disent plus nationaliste et plus
consistent que vous les corses et qui
sont mariés à des femmes corse c'est une
situation absurde sur un plan
idéologique donc il a un dogme simeoni
tous les nationalistes et autonomistes
et indépendantistes en le même homme il
faut reconnaître les droits historiques
du peuple corse mais qu'est ce que c'est
le peuple corse si simone di et formules
ceci s'il dit le peuple corse est partie
intégrante du peuple français ont fait
un bond un bas un pas en avant
extraordinaire ça veut dire que le
nationalisme n'a plus de raison d'être
si le peuple corse a vocation à se
dissocier du peuple français et à une
bible à une existence spécifique séparé
du peuple français alors la seule raison
d'être du nationalisme c'est
l'indépendance il n'y a que deux voix et
c'est pour ça que simeone il est dans
une situation inextricable très
difficile pour lui il est entre deux
rives il faut qu'il choisisse mois pour
moi il est évident que je suis français
et que je suis français par la culture
et par la langue est ce que j'explique
aux nationalistes s'aimer 100% des
corses par les cris français vous
expliquer que c'est la culture qui est
le fondement de l'identité donc soyez
logique si la culture est le fondement
du d'anti les corses tous les corps sont
français culturellement puisqu'on paris
vous les tous et vous écrivez tous en
français simeoni parle un français
remarquable les meilleurs écrivains
corps six écrivains français remarquable
donc ça veut dire que les nationalistes
doivent accepter la dimension culturelle
française de leur identité l'identité
corse où vous me posez la question la
personnalité corse c'est lui tagliani t
la corsitude et aussi la culture
française donc cette petite île de corse
il ya aussi quelque chose qui absorbe
les gens qui rentrent et c'est vrai
qu'on dit souvent que les gens qui
arrivent vote nationaliste assez
volontiers parce qu'ils se disent on est
bien avec ça
si on les emmerde sur le côté de la
violence peut-être changé bon mais mais
l'idée qu'il y ait une façon de parler
une façon de se tenir une musique corse
des chants polyphoniques l'encore
s'étaient tous tout ça forme quelque
chose à l'intérieur encore une fois d'un
périmètre géographique qui est
évidemment mieux dessiner que nulle part
ailleurs donc voilà bon aidants et donc
donc je crois quand même que qu' il faut
trouver lit dans le fait qu'avoir une
identité particulière au sein de la
république n'est pas une tare ça peut
même être quelque chose de positif non
s'il sait tout le monde voulait
comprendre ça où on avancerait un peu
mieux est d'ailleurs une des choses qui
m'inquiètent beaucoup si vous voulez
l'opinion nationale vis-à-vis des corps
c'est quand même très négative il faut
aussi changer ça et moi j'essaye
d'expliquer à mes amis quand vous avez
comme une responsabilité de restaurer
non seulement une corse qui fonctionne
mais une image de la corse dans la
république qui soit beaucoup plus
positive d'ailleurs rien n'a été fait
dans ce sens là parce que les corps sont
quand même assez nombriliste ils pensent
ils ne voient pas et ne voit pas
douteuse là vous avez complètement
raison il n'y a que nous qui pouvons le
dire c'est presque une névrose presque
une névrose identitaire c'est à dire que
ils voient le monde à partir de mai ça
c'est tous les insulaires elise ont été
choqués de voir ces violences dans
bastia des petits jeunes qui jouaient la
guérilla à la guéguerre en sachant bien
qu'on le retirera pas dessus quant à
quelques centaines de kilomètres il ya
une vraie guerre sur un plan sur le plan
de l'image que donne la corse c'est
quand même
désastreux que le maire de bastia ait pu
dire oui ces petits jeunes c'est pas des
racailles ils font bien ils ont cassé
quelques bâtiments publics moi j'ai vu
la poste la poste étaient fermés ils ont
cassé l'entrée de la poste on pouvait
plus accéder à la poste la grande banque
poste de pasques de bastia le lundi avec
des slogans ignoble du genre golo à sale
race des choses comme ça mais qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que les gens moi j'ai
vécu en france 50 ans de ma vie sur le
continent j'ai fait un lapsus mais je
n'ai jamais senti la moindre hostilité
la moindre agressivité à mon égard en
tant que corse ils ont construit une
paranoïa
jamais je n'ai vu un corps se faire
traiter de sale corse sur le continent
gelé dit un député nationaliste qu'est
ce que vous diriez vous quand vous
arrivez à marseille et que vous voyez
sur un mur corse corse d'or rentrez chez
vous qu'est ce que vous diriez c'est là
où je suis un peu plus pessimiste que
charles henri filippi
l'idéologie à une puissance mortifère et
elle pourrit les relations humaines et
les relations sociales ils ont créé un
monde une vision du monde une conception
qui est fondée sur une erreur historique
qui est qu'il est très difficile de leur
faire comprendre ils ont plaqué sur
l'histoire de la corse le schéma
anticoloniale anticolonialiste c'est un
paradoxe puisque les corses ont été les
champions de l'aventuré coloniale ils
ont indiqué des colonialistes hors pair
et à partir des années 60 ils ont
considéré que la corse étaient colonisés
pour qu'ils aient une colonisation il
faut quoi il faut une disparité de
statut il faut une inégalité au niveau
de la citoyenneté jamais la corse n'ont
été des sous citoyens ils ont toujours
eu l'égalité de droit la situation de
l'algérie ou de l'indochine n'a rien à
voir avec la cession de la corse vous
n'avez pas lorsqu'il de l'algérie
étaient colonisés des maghrébins des
algériens qui devenait fonctionnaires
journalistes avocats ministre dans la
république française vous avez vu ça
avec la corse la corse a été à culture
et elle a été sous-estimée elle a été
folkloriser culturellement ça c'est vrai
mais elle n'a jamais été colonie alors
pourquoi ça a marché cette théorie parce
que on confond le colonialisme et la
colonisation culturelle le fait d'être
dominés culturellement on peut dire nous
français aujourd'hui qu'on ait colonisé
par les états unis 6 voulait
culturellement ça veut pas dire qu'on
est dans une société coloniale dans un
statut colonial donc à partir de cette
ambiguïté les nationalistes qui ont dit
notre culture elle a été sous-estimé l a
été colonisé par la france c'est facile
aux jeunes vous leur faites gober
n'importe quoi les nationalistes qui
explique que la corse a été colonisée
ils ont fait une fausse analyse une
erreur faute une erreur idéologique qui
leur a permis de construire leur
conception contre l'état français et
contre la france et maintenant ils
peuvent plus s'en dégager il faut qu'il
fasse un nageur mentaux qui
reconnaissent que peut-être ils se sont
trompés mais vous savez c'est pascal
c'est l'historien que j'aime beaucoup la
de bonaparte gueniffey qui a une formule
extraordinaire pour un homme comme pour
un peuple rien de plus difficile de
reconnaître que l'on s'est trompé
à l'insu contre personnellement la co
officialité de la langue corse par les
le corse tout ce qui permet au corps de
parler le corse qui entraient largement
fait déjà c'est très important et les
corses parle de corse de plus en plus et
c'est ce qui compte ce qui consiste à
dire tout acte
doit être écrit en corse et en français
c'est une distraction la corse doit
rester ouverte au monde et les jeunes
corps doit se projeter dans le monde
donc moi je suis pas pour un
rétrécissement de la course elle-même et
en plus bien sûr je suis d'accord mais
c'est surtout que c'est absurde comme
revendication le génie de la langue
corse est un génie orale quel intérêt
cela a de faire du corse une langue
administrative
vous voyez ci fait remplir vos feuilles
d'impôts en corse ça n'a pas d'intérêt
quoi les nationalistes utilise ce
leitmotiv qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin
toujours d'être de montrer qu'ils ont
qui sont dans un bras de fer avec l'état
pour obtenir quelque chose ils vivent de
ça c'est leur fond de commerce
la crise corsa scalise le signalement
français les corses ils ont une idée de
même assez extraordinaire il faut le
dire et souvenez-vous de ce mauvais
souvenir d'andré santini le maire d'issy
les moulineaux qui écorche corsiste etc
et qui est pas du tout autonomistes et
un jour il a eu cette formule
extraordinaire il ya que deux types
d'hommes ceux qui sont encore si ceux
qui voudraient l'être
voyez ce que je sais c'est marrant mais
même si c'est une blague
même si c'est une blague ça veut dire
que les corses qui s'auto essentialise
même et les français républicain deep
macron ils ont le ils ont le problème
inverse on a l'impression que les
français n'ont pas d'identité
non ils n'ont que des valeurs les
valeurs républicaines des valeurs
citoyennes les corses ne comprennent pas
ils comprennent pas pourquoi il
deviendrait une sorte de petite minorité
à travers d'une france dans une france
complètement hétérogène
multiculturelle et techniquement ils ont
uni seraient eux un petit échantillon
qu'est ce que nous avons en commun au
delà de toutes nos oppositions et de
tous nos antagonismes c'est notre langue
c'est notre culture notamment notre
culture littéraire et vous savez les
corses et des gens qui aiment aussi la
littérature française et la culture
française et les meilleurs écrivains
corse comme jérôme ferrari prix goncourt
andré paradis etc ce sont d'excellents
écrivain français donc ça fait un lien
entre nous en fait le la corse et la
france étaient en phase jeux d'eau
jusqu'aux années 60 dans les années 60
qui avait encore un discours sur la
nation qui était incarné par un homme
qui a été très admiré encore ce qui
était le général de gaulle le
patriotisme français a été en partie
ringardisé beaucoup de français des
nouvelles générations
les bobos notamment l'électorat de mâcon
ont considéré que ces notions était un
peu obsolète encore si vous avez un
rapport à la terre est très important
mais ça c'est pas du tout ringard c'est
quelque chose qui a beaucoup de valeur
sur un plan symbolique et ils ne
comprennent pas ces français ce genre du
continent qui sont des citoyens
administratif voilà donc ça aussi il ya
vraiment un fossé sur cet angle là c'est
vrai qu'en corse
le il ya une forme d'épanouissement
personnel qui est l'appartenance à cette
identité je pense que pour les jeunes
c'est évidemment le cas et donc c'est
vrai que cette identité pour ce problème
on est en train de le voir dans les
drames convient pour l'instant et qu'on
a vécu dans le passé elle est en même
temps c'est pour ça que je suis plus
optimiste que vous si elle était bien
gérée si j'ose dire était bien géré on
devrait trouver dans le monde moderne
le compromis à l'internât glick je ne
parle pas que pour la corse entre une
unité républicaine et des collectivités
qui peuvent être différentes alain cadre
pas du tout communautarisme je parle pas
du communautarisme religieux je parle
des intérêts locaux je parle des
questions décentralisation ont
maintenant il ya une autre chose c'est
que moi dit la nation est surtout
importante pour ceux qui se plaignent
d'elle les corses font partie moi je
trouve de s'est assigné à résidence ce
que qu'on est de toute façon dans les
fêtes complètement dépendant de l'état
on est dépendant vital premier employeur
dans les premiers rangs c'est celle de
la balance des comptes de lille elle est
très négative sans l'état encore
aujourd'hui et je pense que nous faisons
partie d'un de ces peuples de l'archipel
il ya des archipels
sociaux il ya des archipels géographique
il ya un super religieux nous on est un
archipel
identitaire et insulaire j'avoue que
personnellement
je trouve que l'archipel isation
identitaire elle n'est pas forcément
plus mauvaise que l'amertume social du
gilet jaune et surtout pas que les
tendances d'extrémisme religieux de
certains autres donc mais mais mais mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a un lien fort entre
l'évolution la république la manière
dont on la jette pour ça que je disais
tout à l'heure si darmana nous explique
qu'il n'y a qu'un type de français il
dit quelque chose dont on peut rêver
donc on peut aimer mais qui n'est plus
la situation française du jour
moi je suis pour que les mesures qui
sont prises pour adapter au fond la
règle à la situation corse soit prise au
regard des dossiers contrats traités
dans un dialogue approfondi entre la
collectivité de corse et l'état avec ma
croûte me semble devoir être élus
pourront peut-être avec mac os en
première les infos qu'à titre personnel
il traite ce dossier bon allez c'est pas
aussi important que le dossier ukrainien
bien sûr mais pour nous c'est d'une très
grande importance je pense que pour la
france c'est d'une importance est
essentiel aussi
le silence
le silence dans mon village la qualité
du silence mes amis
je quand j'arrive là-bas il ya j'ai un
collectif d'amis qui sont les amis
corses de corse et des amis corses qui
reviennent de paris mme meyer et
j'éprouve un très très grand plaisir à
ces rapports qui sont réduites ou
métalliques non c'est vrai qu'il ya il
ya quelque chose de chaud il y avait et
fiabilité il ya une sociabilité
spontanée qui fait partie des vertus ce
pays